hello reject nation we are going to
watch today a new trailer release for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness it's a 30 second tv spot
apparently featuring some new footage i
can't wait to see what this opens up the
door for now that morbius is out um
leave a like if you can we're gonna talk
about whatever's in here and uh also the
run time was revealed for this movie i
do i do have some thoughts on that that
we'll share after talking about this
little spot lastly tickets are gonna go
on sale this week not saying where i'm
going because i don't want too much
competition for when i'm scouring amc
universal tickets this coming wednesday
good save
my dead center seats i'm aiming for amc
universal
imax in hollywood theater yeah in the
universe
of florida california yeah california if
you see me there
don't say hi
but i love attention so come up to me
and talk to me just don't say hi just
don't say hi but you know if you want a
photo i'll only do videos
will you record a tick tock with me
the multiverse
it's life or death
you could use an avenger
yeah you can't other avengers we'll get
you back on the lunchbox
mordo
clear shot oh
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness tickets on sale this wednesday
hold up oh we gotta watch that again
yeah is that good thought i think i
think it must be let's see looks like
that character that was on the poster
needs to say
the multiverse
it's life i love the colors man this
could use an avenger
there are other avengers i'll get you
back on the lunchbox you're the most
magical wanda
looks like definitely the commentary
moment
the fate of the multiverse
depends on us no pressure then
he's behind them in the multiverse of
madness tickets on sale this wednesday i
keep trying to figure out like what
moment in the movie would that be from
well yeah and the demons fighting
alongside them exactly yeah
at first i was like oh okay so he's
gotta come like they're dealing with the
dark hole it only makes sense for
cathode to show up but then to have him
actually not seemingly attacking wang
and wanda is a little funky well i think
one conclusion one can draw is that with
wanda now control the dark hole maybe
whatever other entities they're up
against she manages to use if that is
cathon i mean it's like i find it kind
of hard to believe that they would just
reveal catholic in this manner but it
looks exactly like
it looks like the live action version of
catholic you know what it looks like so
i would imagine that maybe because she's
fighting alongside wong
and whatever this demon is and then
they're going up against something or
someone so she's able to control
um whoever you know that demon is or at
least find a way to have that demon aid
in them i still think she's the bad guy
in the movie like that there's just one
shot where she's like hovering above
what looks like that moment in the
previous trailer when that big black
smoke comes in and consumes kamar taj
and it looks like that's her floating
above it but really the big takeaway
from this trailer is um wait which
know which one's the one is
maria forget it whoever the mom is i
want to captain marvel uh i think it's
maria maria rambo's mom yeah monica
rambo's daughter i believe that's the
way it goes anyway yeah i've heard many
speculation about who this character is
whether that be monica or maria rambo or
tom cruise's superior man i think it
would just be so cool to like bring her
back after captain marvel
let her have some type of
multiverse version if it is the mcu
version i highly doubt it but if it's a
different version from the multiverse
who's part of the illuminati who's like
using some of the ultron bot gear i
think that would be really cool and a
great way to like tease her transition
into photon or spectrum or whatever they
ultimately decide to call her character
in the future of the actual mcu timeline
you know i just got to say like the
cinematography on all these shots like
that's what makes every new shot
exciting is they all pop everything the
colors pop and that's one thing that i
think is so great about getting sam
raimi on board for this movie is the the
cinematography really shines like if you
compare a lot of the way the imagery
looks here versus some other mcu joints
or even the previous doctor strange
movie everything just like the word that
comes to mind is pop no exactly it's got
that sam raimi sort of zap and zing to
it it's got the energy but also in a way
that doesn't make me weary because like
if you look at a lot of sam raimi
blockbuster trailers for the previous
like tentpole movies he's done you know
there's something that feels almost
artificial about them where this
actually while it has all the crazy mcu
effects we would expect it still feels
like tangible in a way and it still
feels like it's a movie like an actual
movie and not just sort of like a cgi
mess which is what you would hope for
especially with the such a potential for
all these different effects driven
worlds colliding together so it's like
the biggest production in a way i could
imagine for sam raimi but at the same
time it doesn't look like it's falling
into some of the pitfalls that his
blockbusters have been subject to in the
past it gives me hope
for this
now we gotta talk about the runtime the
runtime actually has me legit concerned
i was already a little bit wary you know
hearing all the rumors about this movie
and granted you might have seen on the
channel that we actually made a decision
to ah maybe we shouldn't cover as much
leaks as we once did you know so we we
haven't really been following any of the
actual leaks that have been coming out
um but needless to say it's really
obvious they are jam-packing a lot into
this one movie and so the reporter run
time because some theaters did like they
they have the tickets to go up already
some theaters already like here's what
the show times are gonna be so be
prepared and the run time is two hours
and six minutes
and i think that's remarkably short for
everything that's going to be in this
one movie supposedly right when you're
hearing about the cameos the characters
opening up the world calling it
multiverse of madness now a lot of this
could come down to just
proper tone and just really tight
scripting
but you know it's though some of the
rumors that i've heard granted it's just
rumors that they seem likely is that
like the original cup for this movie was
three hours long before they had to end
up trimming it down i mean spider-man no
way home
that in and of itself was two and a half
hours or somewhere around there i forget
the exact run time but but it warranted
that run time and you saw how much it
benefited from having that run time and
just been knowing what's in this movie
so far yeah like i feel like you need a
little bit of a longer run time so it
doesn't feel rushed yeah and with the
amount of importance that this movie
seems to be carrying within the fact
that it does seem like a more avengers
world like they literally name check the
avengers in this trailer there's a lot
of cross over here beyond just
multiverse stuff it seems like they're
going to decide some very important
things for just the fabric of the mcu
multiverse moving forward and so yeah
while i'm not necessarily worried by the
runtime it is a fascinating prospect to
me because this is only about 10 minutes
longer than doctor strange and you know
it's not supposed to be as contained a
movie as doctor strange and i mean that
managed to pack a whole lot of craziness
into that hour and 55 minutes or
whatever but yeah part of me wonders
well maybe they really streamline the
story and maybe despite all of the crazy
world hopping and character bending
we'll see maybe they did just
really tighten the main plot to keep it
you know contained and organized and all
that but at the same time yeah you
expect a two and a half hour movie at
least for something as big and broad and
important seeming as this movie is
well what do you guys think about the
runtime leave your thoughts down below
you can subscribe click that bell
hey
let's do a page
mitchell reed per being a new patron
traditional shout out time m for
multiverse i for incredible t for
tremendously incredible c for cool
h for hell yeah mitchell e for excellent
l for love you
and l for lick you yeah mitchell we're
gonna lick love you to hell
thanks for being part of the patreon
page
be well welcome mother effort
[Music]